Musique angoissante
...
-Elle est un bien précieux,
notre poumon vert,
une réserve de biodiversité.
Avec ses 17 millions d'hectares,
la forêt française
est un maillon essentiel
de la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique.
C'est le deuxième puits de carbone
après les océans,
mais notre forêt souffre.
...
Elle est en danger,
menacée par les effets
du réchauffement climatique,
par les sécheresses à répétition
et la rapidité
de ces bouleversements.
...
En 10 ans,
la mortalité des arbres
a augmenté de 80 %.
Leur croissance
a beaucoup ralenti,
et la capacité de nos forêts
à stocker du carbone diminue.
Un défi majeur :
comment réinventer la forêt,
la sauver,
pour qu'elle nous sauve ?
...
Musique douce
Au coeur de la Côte-d'Or,
au nord de Dijon,
le domaine de Jugny.
Une forêt de grands hêtres
présente ici
depuis la dernière glaciation,
il y a 10 000 ans.
...
-Voilà.
C'est ici qu'on a repéré
beaucoup de dépérissement
sur le massif.
C'est pour ça qu'on voulait
vous le montrer.
-Il manque
plein de feuilles, en haut,
sur les branches,
elles sont rouges.
Ils ont souffert.
-Et puis t'as plein
de branches mortes,
dans le houppier.
Tu vois bien
que ça va pas s'améliorer
à la saison prochaine.
Moins t'as de feuilles,
moins t'as de chances
que ça redémarre bien
au printemps.
-Lilian Duband
et Brigitte Musch
sont spécialistes
du changement climatique
à l'Office national
des forêts.
Après un nouvel été
caniculaire,
ils viennent constater
les dégâts.
-Ce qui est dur à vivre,
c'est qu'on voit des hêtres,
principalement,
qui sont là depuis des générations,
des centaines d'années,
qui arrivaient bien à pousser ici
et qui n'y arrivent plus.
Les choses ont vraiment commencé
en 2018
mais ne font
que s'amplifier depuis.
-Les hêtres ne résistent plus
aux canicules
et surtout aux sécheresses
à répétition.
Le sol est tellement sec
qu'ils n'ont plus
assez d'eau
pour amener la sève
jusqu'à leurs feuilles.
-On voit qu'il suffit
de quelques années
pour qu'un arbre qui a mis
plus de 100 ans à pousser meure.
Là, c'est l'arbre qui meurt,
c'est l'accueil qu'il pouvait faire
à un certain nombre d'espèces.
C'est le carbone qu'il était
capable de stocker.
Un grand arbre,
avec toutes ses feuilles,
il peut vraiment capter
du carbone.
Là, il en capte presque plus
et quand il mourra,
il va relarguer ce carbone.
On voit que le bois
est, disons,
en proie aux éléments.
Il se dégrade et on va avoir
du mal à le valoriser
pour en faire des meubles,
par exemple.
-C'est double peine.
-C'est plus qu'une double peine,
c'est de la peine
sur tous les rôles que jouent
les arbres dans l'écosystème
et pour nous aussi, humains.
La parcelle, la quasi-totalité
des arbres va mourir.
C'est dur pour nous.
S'il y avait une espèce,
bon, voilà,
c'est parce qu'il y a
une maladie particulière,
mais non.
Avec les changements
climatiques,
tout l'écosystème n'est pas adapté
à ce climat-là.
C'est ça dont on voit
les conséquences.
-Quelques kilomètres
plus loin,
une autre espèce
est attaquée.
Les épicéas meurent
les uns après les autres,
décimés en quelques mois
par un insecte.
-On voit que
c'est en cours, ouais.
En même temps, avec la chaleur
qu'il fait, fin septembre,
les conditions sont réunies
pour qu'ils attaquent.
-Cet insecte,
c'est le scolyte.
-Là, il a creusé sa galerie
pour pondre.
C'est tout petit,
ça fait 2 mm de long
et ensuite, les larves,
hop, qui se nourrissent
en mangeant
la partie du bois
qui est juste sous l'écorce,
les petites larves sont là,
toutes blanches,
donc avec les chaleurs
qu'il fait,
elles vont continuer
leur croissance, etc.
Comme l'hiver,
il fait pas assez froid
pour les faire mourir,
elles vont aller attaquer
d'autres épicéas
l'année prochaine.
-Regardez les larves
qui tombent,
il est complètement infesté.
-Pourquoi les scolytes
se développent autant que ça ?
Ils sont favorisés
par les températures.
Là, ils devraient pas être
aussi actifs que ça
fin septembre,
et les arbres
sont trop stressés
et n'arrivent plus
à se défendre.
Là, il y a vraiment peu de choses
qu'on peut faire.
-Affaiblis par la sécheresse,
les épicéas
n'ont plus assez de résine
pour se défendre.
Ici encore, c'est toute la parcelle
qui va mourir.
-On est très inquiets pour l'avenir,
nous, les forestiers.
On voit les arbres
qui sont en train de mourir,
Tous les jours, avec les collègues,
on est en forêt,
et ce qu'on voit, c'est les attaques
du changement climatique,
et d'année en année,
c'est pire.
C'est comme une boule de neige
qui grossit et qui grossit.
Musique douce
-La forêt est affaiblie
par le réchauffement
climatique,
mais pas seulement.
Aujourd'hui,
les pratiques forestières
sont remises en question,
accusées de fragiliser la forêt,
comme la monoculture.
Pour des raisons
économiques,
pour développer
la filière bois
et la rentabiliser,
dans certaines régions,
des massifs entiers ont été plantés
avec une seule espèce.
Quand les arbres
de ces plantations linéaires
arrivent à maturité,
ils sont tous coupés
en même temps,
laissant le sol à nu.
C'est la coupe rase.
C'est ce qui s'est passé
dans le Morvan.
-Le problème, ça a commencé
dans les années 70.
C'est quand là, justement,
l'Etat a estimé
que la balance commerciale
pour la forêt
était en déficit,
donc a incité
à planter énormément
de résineux.
Par tous les moyens,
il fallait faire du bois
avec les résineux,
le matériel était
pour les résineux.
Et donc, petit à petit,
ça a été très, très vite.
Il y a eu une mainmise
par les investisseurs
qui était assez terrible
sur le Morvan,
et les propriétaires
morvandiaux
ne sont pas exempts
de reproche.
Ils se sont empressés
de vendre leurs forêts.
-Lucienne
est une pionnière.
Depuis 40 ans,
elle se bat
contre l'exploitation intensive
de la forêt.
-C'est un spectacle
de désolation.
Il y a eu une coupe rase
de tout le peuplement
sur toute la parcelle.
On est passé
avec les gros engins.
C'est l'exemple même
de ce qui se passe
dans le Morvan et ailleurs.
Là, on coupe
des forêts de feuillus.
On aurait très bien pu
éclaircir.
La coupe rase,
ça devrait être
une décision ultime.
C'est quand on peut plus
faire autrement,
pas quand on a
d'autres solutions.
-Celle qu'on surnomme
affectueusement
Lulu du Morvan
est devenue le visage
de ce combat
pour sauver
la forêt traditionnelle.
-La représentation de ce qu'est
une belle forêt, ici.
Quand on s'est battus
pour le domaine de Montmain,
ce chêne m'a tout de suite plu.
C'est "le chêne à Lulu".
Ce chêne, moi, d'abord,
je dis que mes cendres,
je veux
qu'elles soient mises
au pied de ce chêne.
Il est magnifique.
C'est le symbole de la lutte
pour sauver le domaine de Montmain.
C'est toute mon histoire
depuis mon enfance.
-Ici, les industriels
voulaient faire
de la forêt de Montmain
une monoculture
de résineux.
-Imaginons ici,
cette beauté de la forêt,
une monoculture
de Douglas.
C'est terrible.
Vous avez une forêt,
il y a plus rien
qui vit dessous.
-Alors,
Lucienne a créé le premier
groupement forestier citoyen,
des femmes et des hommes
qui s'unissent
pour acheter la forêt
et la gérer
de manière durable.
Ensemble, ils ont pu
sauver ce domaine.
-Vous savez,
la forêt, elle est pas
simplement un produit.
C'est pas un produit de bois
consommable à foison.
La forêt,
c'est aussi pour les sols,
la qualité des sols,
pour l'eau.
C'est très lié
à la biodiversité.
On parle
du changement climatique.
C'est sûr qu'il existe.
Mais les monocultures
d'épicéas...
Si les épicéas
avaient été plantés
en mélange
avec des feuillus,
on aurait pas
à tout ratiboiser.
J'en veux à la politique forestière
en haut lieu,
aux ministères, à nos élus,
parce que les lois,
elles sont votées par nos députés,
par nos sénateurs,
et qu'est-ce qu'ils font
jusqu'à maintenant ?
Qu'est-ce qu'ils font
devant l'impact climatique ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on essaie de faire
pour limiter la casse ?
-A 82 ans, sa révolte
et son engagement
restent intacts.
Les écologistes se battent
depuis des années
contre les monocultures
et les coupes rases
pour permettre aux forêts
de mieux résister
au changement climatique.
Une idée
qui commence à faire son chemin
chez certains forestiers,
comme ici,
dans la Nièvre.
-On peut pas revenir
sur le passé.
Ce qui a été fait,
c'est des plantations
qui datent de 40-60 ans.
Oui, c'est des erreurs...
Jusqu'à temps qu'il y ait
les mortalités,
on disait pas
que c'était des erreurs,
parce que c'était un schéma
qui fonctionnait,
qui était rentable,
mais aujourd'hui,
manifestement,
on sait qu'on n'est plus
dans le vrai.
C'est important
d'en tenir compte,
et à nous d'évoluer,
maintenant.
Je reconnais aussi
que les écologistes
ont participé à faire évoluer
les mentalités.
C'est une bonne chose,
mais aujourd'hui,
on est à un stade où,
justement,
les forestiers
ont pris conscience
de certaines choses,
et l'idée,
c'est d'être dans la discussion
et les échanges
plutôt que de critiquer
systématiquement.
-Alexandre Couvenant
gère des forêts
de petits propriétaires
privés.
Sur cette parcelle,
il doit abattre
les 30 hectares
de peupliers et de frênes.
Les arbres sont presque tous
morts de sécheresse
ou d'un champignon,
la chalarose.
Seuls les chênes
sont épargnés.
-Les coupes rases,
c'est pas un choix,
c'est quelque chose
de subi.
C'est sûr
qu'on aurait préféré
faire une coupe
d'éclaircie,
parce que c'est ce qu'on pratique
en temps normal,
pour faire, justement,
profiter les arbres
d'avenir
et, à terme,
récolter du bois d'oeuvre,
et là, actuellement,
c'est pas possible.
-L'intervention est trop risquée
pour les bûcherons,
alors Alexandre a fait appel
à une abatteuse.
-C'est un travail très dangereux
lorsqu'il y a du bois sec,
donc il faut
du matériel robuste,
même si on trouve que c'est gros,
mais c'est la seule façon
pour pouvoir exploiter
ce type de bois.
-Ce bois n'aurait dû
être récolté
que dans 20 ans.
Il a perdu toute sa valeur.
-Il y a uniquement
les quelques résineux
qui vont partir en scierie,
mais c'est anecdotique.
Sinon, le frêne va partir
en bois de chauffage,
et le peuplier
va être transformé,
soit en panneaux
de particules
ou en OSB,
éventuellement en papier.
-Face à cette situation,
Alexandre est démuni.
Il a beau
diversifier ses forêts,
travailler en futaie irrégulière,
avec plusieurs
essences d'arbres,
de différentes tailles,
qu'il récolte petit à petit,
ils sont quand même malades.
-Aujourd'hui,
en voulant faire pour le mieux,
on n'est sûr de rien.
C'est vraiment terrible.
Il faudra
s'adapter,
c'est une certitude.
Savoir quelle essence mettre
avec certitude,
c'est impossible,
donc on va faire des essais,
essayer d'y croire.
-On sent que c'est dur,
humainement.
-Oui,
c'est sûr
que c'est difficile.
Forcément, on croit moins
dans ce qu'on fait,
donc c'est...
On a envie d'y croire.
On sait que...
Autant nos prédécesseurs,
ils plantaient,
ils se posaient pas la question
et ça allait au bout,
ils travaillaient la forêt
tel qu'ils savaient le faire
et ça fonctionnait.
Aujourd'hui, même en se posant
beaucoup de questions,
on n'est sûr de rien.
En voulant faire pour le mieux,
Voilà. C'est très...
C'est pas facile à vivre,
ouais.
...
-La filière
n'a plus le choix.
Elle doit s'adapter
et trouver un équilibre
entre économie
et écologie.
...
En Auvergne,
même le sapin,
pourtant endémique,
ne résiste plus.
Les changements climatiques
vont très vite,
trop vite
à l'échelle de l'arbre.
Christian et Chantal
ont hérité de plusieurs
petites parcelles de forêt.
-On voit qu'ils sont
en train de mourir
et ça gagne, en fait.
Le dépérissement...
-On voit celui-là, aussi.
-...s'étend.
-Conseillé par leur coopérative
forestière,
sur cette parcelle
d'un hectare,
le couple a décidé
de couper
l'ensemble
des sapins malades
pour replanter
d'autres espèces.
-Il y a du sycomore,
plus loin, il y a du Douglas...
-Le sycomore,
on le voit, il a bien,
bien pris.
-C'est un pari
sur l'avenir.
-Un érable.
-Là, c'est un érable ?
-Oui.
-On n'a pas
une science exacte,
et donc, il faut essayer,
innover, mélanger,
utiliser tous les modes de culture
qui existent
pour savoir lequel permettra
d'avoir une belle forêt
pour nos générations
futures.
-Sur d'autres parcelles
de sapins,
ces forestiers de la coopérative
ont fait un choix
différent.
-Il y a pas une solution.
Il y a pas une seule solution
quand on arrive
devant un peuplement,
et j'allais dire,
on peut proposer des choses
au propriétaire,
soit de récolter,
parce que le propriétaire
a peur pour la suite
de son peuplement,
et légitimement,
soit de faire une éclaircie.
-Donc là, la solution
qu'on a mise en place
avec le propriétaire,
ça a été de récolter
uniquement les bois secs,
en espérant que les sapins
qui sont là
puissent encore
continuer à progresser
et miser un peu d'avenir
sur eux, malgré les effets
du réchauffement climatique.
On aura moins de souches
qui vont pomper l'eau,
et donc, ceux qui sont là,
on espère qu'ils vont en profiter
le mieux possible.
Il va moins pleuvoir,
mais s'ils sont moins
à se partager l'eau,
on espère que ça leur permettra
de passer le cap.
Après, on a essayé de garder
le mélange d'essences
au maximum.
Les quelques essences
qu'on avait en accompagnement,
on les a favorisées.
On a un hêtre, un chêne,
un châtaignier.
C'est peut-être celui-ci
qui sera une essence d'avenir
sur cette parcelle.
-En France,
75 % de la forêt est privée,
et elle est très morcelée.
Plus de 2 millions
de propriétaires
possèdent
moins d'un hectare.
Aucune réglementation
ne s'impose à eux,
car en dessous de 25 hectares,
chacun gère sa forêt
comme il veut.
-Le propriétaire forestier
reste maître chez lui.
Donc nous proposons des choses
au propriétaire,
mais jamais nous n'allons
lui imposer quelque chose.
Un propriétaire qui voudrait
mettre une seule essence
et qui respecte
la réglementation,
il serait libre
de le faire.
-Mais ce n'est plus
ce que vous conseillez.
-C'est jamais
ce qu'on conseille,
sauf si les parcelles
sont très petites,
auquel cas, le fait de mettre
plusieurs essences
compliquerait la gestion
de la parcelle.
-Ca veut dire aussi qu'on arrête
les coupes rases ?
-On va pas en finir
avec les coupes rases.
La futaie régulière
est un mode de sylviculture
tout à fait valable,
comme la futaie
irrégulière
est un mode de sylviculture
tout à fait valable.
Comme on vous l'a dit,
il faut pas mettre tous nos oeufs
dans le même panier.
On ne va plus faire
de coupes de récolte
sur des dizaines d'hectares,
comme à une certaine époque.
Ca, ce serait
un mauvais conseil
aux propriétaires forestiers,
sauf impasse sylvicole
due par exemple à des peuplements
dépérissants,
mais un peuplement
qui pousse normalement,
on va l'accompagner,
et s'il y a
des récoltes à faire,
on va plutôt morceler
ces récoltes
que de le faire
sur des dizaines d'hectares.
-Si la forêt ne réussit plus
à s'adapter seule,
comment l'aider ?
Nous retrouvons Brigitte Musch,
la généticienne de l'ONF,
près de Dijon.
-Celui-là, on voit très bien
qu'il a eu un souci.
Je me demande même
s'il est pas reparti
depuis les dernières pluies.
-Elle pilote
le projet Giono,
un programme
de migration assistée.
Les scientifiques
ont introduit des arbres
qui ne poussaient pas
naturellement ici.
-Du coup, on a recréé des bandes
dans lesquelles
on a planté, on est venus.
Là, il y a des chênes.
-Là, c'est des chênes
pubescents.
Ces petits chênes pubescents,
on voit bien, là,
il y a des petits poils,
et ces poils-là,
ils lui servent à moins...
-Perdre d'eau.
-...moins perdre d'eau, voilà,
moins subir l'air sec.
Donc c'est vraiment un intérêt.
C'est un chêne
qui vient du sud de la France,
de Provence,
et du coup, c'est une piste vraiment
intéressante pour nous ici.
-Et pour cette espèce
en particulier,
le chêne pubescent,
on a bien fait
la migration assistée.
C'est une espèce
qui est présente
dans le sud de la France
et qu'on a apportée
par mains d'humain,
enfin humainement,
jusqu'ici.
Avec un réchauffement...
S'il avait été
beaucoup plus progressif,
il aurait pu, en dizaines
de milliers d'années,
potentiellement reconquérir
naturellement
le nord de la France,
mais c'est pas le cas.
-Ils ont aussi planté
des cèdres du Liban
issus des forêts
du Luberon.
-Donc on aide la nature
à faire ce qu'elle aurait fait
classiquement.
Et nous,
il faut qu'on mise
avec tout ce qu'on sait
pour l'instant
de la science,
des arts de la foresterie,
et qu'on réinvente
quelque chose de nouveau
pour continuer
à avoir une forêt
qui rend tous ces services
écosystémiques.
-L'ONF a aussi développé
des îlots d'avenir.
Sur des petites parcelles,
ils testent
des espèces exotiques
qui n'étaient pas présentes
en France
jusqu'à maintenant.
Sur celle-ci,
ils ont planté
du calocèdre.
-C'est un résineux qui ressemble
à un cyprès ou à un thuya.
Il est originaire
de la côte ouest
des Etats-Unis,
Californie.
Dans des conditions
d'origine,
il montre une très bonne résistance
à la sécheresse
tout en étant dans des conditions
d'altitude
où il y a de la neige l'hiver,
du grand froid.
-Ce sont des espèces
pour lesquelles
on connaît pas forcément
grand-chose,
qui ont pas été introduites
largement
en France et en Europe,
et donc, on a besoin
de références,
à la fois sur le taux de survie,
sur la croissance,
sur l'appétence au gibier,
la résistance
au stress hydrique.
-Pas question pour autant de jouer
aux apprentis sorciers.
L'espèce est
très surveillée.
-On a potentiellement
toujours
un risque
pour la biodiversité.
C'est pour ça qu'on a introduit
ces espèces
de manière expérimentale,
et on va regarder
comment elle interagit
avec l'écosystème autour,
et en particulier
les problèmes d'invasivité,
qui sont le problème majeur
des espèces exotiques.
Après,
on ne va pas couvrir la forêt
avec du calocèdre,
mais ça fait partie
du panel d'espèces
que l'on pourra proposer
à un peu plus grande échelle
qu'un demi-hectare
dans quelques forêts.
Musique douce
-Entre les dépérissements
et les nouvelles essences,
dans 50 ans,
le visage de nos forêts
va évoluer.
-Nos paysages vont changer,
mais si on a,
comme on le prévoit,
une méditerranéisation
de la forêt plus au nord,
on va avoir une forêt
méditerranéenne,
donc des arbres qui vont être
plus petits aussi.
Donc il faut vraiment s'attendre
à des arbres plus petits
et à des productions de bois
moins importantes.
-Loin de cette forêt
du futur,
dans le Morvan,
Lucienne et son association
tentent aussi à leur façon
de préserver la forêt
et sa biodiversité.
-Bon, Lucienne, tu la trouves
comment, ta forêt ?
-Ben je la trouve belle.
Les souches,
regarde si c'est beau.
Ca gêne pas pour exploiter,
et en plus, c'est la biodiversité
formidable, quoi.
-En 20 ans,
Lucienne et le groupement forestier
ont racheté 20 forêts,
350 hectares au total
qu'ils ont confiés
à Tristan Susse.
L'expert gère et exploite
les arbres,
car la forêt
n'est pas sous cloche :
elle a aussi
un rôle économique.
-Ici, on applique un traitement
en futaie dite irrégulière.
C'est une gestion forestière
qui doit répondre
à des intérêts économiques
et écologiques.
On cherche à avoir ici
différentes essences,
maintenir les essences présentes,
comme le hêtre, le chêne,
le bouleau, des résineux,
et on cherche à avoir
une structuration
du peuplement,
c'est-à-dire
des petits arbres,
des moyens, des gros
et des très gros.
Economiquement, c'est viable.
Ca rapporte moins d'argent
dans les premiers temps,
mais au fur et à mesure,
ça va en rapporter.
-C'est un modèle
transposable ?
-On essaye de le transposer
sur toutes les forêts
en France,
que ce soit
du pin maritime,
du sapin, du hêtre
ou du chêne.
-Pour eux,
c'est la seule façon
d'avoir des forêts
plus résilientes
face au changement
climatique.
Ils aimeraient que ce modèle
devienne la norme.
-Moi, je suis émerveillée
de voir le résultat,
et je suis fière
d'avoir participé à ça.
Je me dis :
t'as pas perdu ton temps
quand tu t'es battue.
Il faut passer
un message optimiste,
parce que
si on commence à dire
"tout est foutu, la forêt
commence à être malade,
"les plantations, on sait pas
si elles vont tenir ou pas",
c'est quand même
assez terrible.
On peut pas se passer
de la forêt.
-Non mais si le GIEC
dit que dans 50 ans,
la température va
augmenter de 4 degrés,
que ce soit du résineux
ou du feuillu,
à mon avis, il n'y aura plus
d'arbres. Ca, c'est clair.
-Mais alors, c'est terrible
de penser ça.
Parce que
les générations futures,
comment on peut faire,
de vivre
dans un monde stérile ?
Moi, je veux pas y croire.
Je dis que quand même,
tous ensemble,
on peut avancer.
-Moi, je dis qu'il faut faire
le moins mal possible.
...
-Aider la forêt à se régénérer
par elle-même,
à s'adapter génétiquement,
préserver son sol,
sa diversité d'essences
et donc sa biodiversité,
autant de défis
pour sauver la forêt,
pour qu'elle continue
de stocker du carbone
et reste notre poumon vert.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...